bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans savauarde ce soir
gros plan sur le ramass l'organisation
terroriste qui a commis les massacre à
grande échelle en Israël bonsoir Michel
prasan vous êtes grand reporter vous
êtes documentariste et vous avez enquêté
sur cette organisation émanation des
Frères musulmans on a besoin de
comprendre vous vous avez retracé
l'histoire des Frères musulmans dans un
de vos films on y reviendra on a plein
de questions ce soir sur les buts les
stratégie et puis la vision du monde de
cette organisation on en parle tous les
deux dans la deuxème partie notre grand
débat ce soir que faire des fichers s
après l'attentat d'aras Gérald daranin
affirme que seul son projet de loi sur
l'immigration aurait permis d'expulser
l'assassin de Dominique Bernard le
ministre de l'Intérieur demande au
parleement de voter ces mesures de
fermeté quitte à adapter voire à
suspendre l'État de droit nous en
débattrons enfin nos affranchis ce soir
l'économie avec Fanny guinochet carte
blanche ce soir au prof d'histoire Yanis
roder et puis rien ne va plus à la Nupe
en pleine désintégration s'en sera dans
le bourbon express de Elsa Mondin Gava
voilà pour le menu on y va Michel
présent ça vous regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
le gouvernement cherche donc la parade
après l'attentat d'aras géralde daranin
renvoie le législateur à ses
responsabilités à l'Assemblée notamment
en lui demandant et bien tout simplement
de voter son texte l'assassin de
Dominique Bernard aurait pu être expulsé
selon lui si ce texte était déjà en
vigueur alors madame et Messieurs les
Députés êtes-vous prêt à le voter
bonsoir Benoît mournet bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes député Renaissance des Hautes
Pyrénées vous débattez ce soir avec
votre collègue Thomas ménager bonsoir
député du rassemblement national du
Loiret bonsoir Marie-Christine dalallose
bonsoir bienvenue à vous députés les
républicains du Jura et bonsoir Philippe
Brun ravi de vous accueillir vous êtes
député socialiste de l'heure je précise
que vous avez été juge administratif ce
qui peut être utile à ce débat sur
l'immigration assez technique merci à
tous les 4 on commence par planter le le
décor politique dans le chrono de blo
tout de
suite
et bonsoir mon cher Stéphane blakovski
je me retourne bonsir bonsoir à toutes
et tous alors ce projet de loi
immigration bien c'est l'actualité avec
l'attentat de haras qui l'a remis à la
unee parce que faut bien reconnaître que
ces derniers temps il était un peu
coincé dans les tiroirs faut dire que
regardez c'était il y a quasiment un an
Gérald armanin et olivierop nous
présentai main dans la main leur projet
de loi immigration et intégration et
optimiste parce qu'il pensait qu'il
pourrait voter début 2023 bon sauf que
début 2023 bien des magnif manifestation
record contre la la réforme des
retraites et donc le président a préféré
reporter le projet il voulait même le
découper voyez avec un texte sur
l'immigration et puis un texte sur
l'intégration donc sa terregiverse pas
mal à l'Élysée sa tergiverse aussi pas
mal à Matignon on avait du parfois du
mal à suivre le plan d'Élisabeth borne à
ce sujet puisque d'un côté à la fin
d'avril elle voulait reporter l'examen à
l'automne et puis finalement 15 jours
plus tard non on va plutôt le faire à la
dès le mois de juillet voulait hâter les
choses bon après temps de once
contradictoire en définitif c'était plus
vraiment la prioritaire puisqu'on
parlait d'un examen de ce texte
printemps 2024 or évidemment l'attentat
a a changé un peu la donne et Bron Pivet
disait hier qu'elle souhaitait accélérer
en l'écoute moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que ce texte soit examiné à l'Assemblée
dès le mois de décembre pour que l'on
puisse avoir un texte si nous parvenons
à un accord avec nos collègues sénateurs
ce que je ne doute pas comp tenu des
circonstances un texte qui serait voté
définitivement avant la fin de l'année
alors on parle de l'effet de l'actualité
sur ce projet celui qui se retrouve sous
la pression de l'actualité c'est Gérald
dararmanin qui d'un côté à qui LR
demande des comptes le RN demande même
la démission donc il a eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer ce matin sur RTL en disant
que en fait futur assassin avait été
interpellé parce queil avait battu sa
mère que la préfecture du pcalais avait
suggéré une ocutf une obligation de
quitter le territoire français mais que
la direction générique juridique de son
ministère avait dit la justice ne sera
jamais d'accord donc selon lui il est
urgent de voter ça on écoute son
argument j'ai besoin des mesures de
fermeté que va me donner le Parlement
pour expulser tout étranger qui commet
des actes délinquences quel qu'il soit
des violences entrafamiliales des
atteintes aux policiers bien sûr des
trafics de drogue qui n'ont rien à voir
avec le terrorisme parce qu'on sait
qu'ils sont souvent l'antichambre des
passage à l'acte et si la loi quand la
loi sera votée le plus rapidement
possible je pourrais appliquer avec les
policiers l'expulsion de tout étranger
délinquant alors est-ce que si la loi
avait été votée avant elle aurait permis
d'éviter cette attentat les républicains
sont pas d'accord d'ailleurs Olivier
marlex sexprimé cet après-midi lors des
questions gouvernement en expliquant que
au mieux si la loi avait été mise en
œuvre on aurait pu délivrer une eqtf au
futur assassin mais qui n'aurait pas
forcément été expulsé on écoute tous
ceux qui sont passés par le ministère de
l'Intérieur le savent en matière
d'expulsion des étrangers c'est le juge
qui a le dernier mot c'est le juge qui
souscouvert d'interpréter les traités
ordonne que tant d'qtf soi relâché dans
la nature alors madame la Première
ministre face à cette impuissance
organisée la seule réponse c'est de
changer la
constitution alors pour soutenir le
projet de de référendum dont on parlait
là les républicains s'appuient souvent
sur les sondages qui prouve qu'une
majorité de Français voudrait stopper
freiner l'immigration c'est vrai
regardez pendant l'arrivée massive des
migrants Lampedusa une majorité de
Français souhaitait ben qu'il ne soit
pas accueillli en Europe mais dans le
même sondage le même panel de personnes
quand on leur demandait s'ils étaient
favoraable à une régularisation des
travailleurs pour les métiers enention
il y a avait aussi une majorité qui
était favorable ça veut donc dire que
l'opinion publique française serait
plutôt sur la même face que le
gouvernement pour son projet de loi
immigration et intégration mais est-ce
qu'il sera voté à l'assemblée dans
quelles conditions qui sera d'accordou
c'est pas encore fait en tout cas c'est
sûr merci beaucoup Stéphane Benoît
mournaay on va reprendre très clairement
les mots de de Gérald daranin cette loi
aurait vraiment évité l' tente d'aras on
parle du verrou des 13 ans hein c'est
vraiment ça qui est mis en avant par
Gérald daranin qui permet de faire
sauter l'interdiction pour tout étranger
en situation irrégulière radicalisé qui
présente une menace ou qui a commis une
infraction d'être expulsé si il est
arrivé sur le territoire français avant
ces 1 ans B effectivement il y a cette
disposition mais comme vous l'avez très
bien rappelé dans votre édito c'est pas
une loi de réaction à des actes
terroristes qui se sont commis qui ont
été malheureusement commis tout
récemment c'est une loi qui est
travaillée depuis plusieurs mois et qui
s'inscrit dans une continuité d'action
par que le quinquen précédent notamment
a permis d'accélérer notamment avec la
ce qu'on appelait les Gudas les les les
guichets uniques demandeurs d'asile mais
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
y a un grand engorgement des tribunaux
administratifs avec une procédure du
droit d'asile qui est fondamentale mais
qui est parfois détourné de son objet
donc il y a dans ce texte une volonté de
refonder la procédure d'asile pour
qu'elle elle soit effectivement ce
pourquoi elle est prévue il y a aussi
dans ce texte et c'est très important on
peut pas complètement découper
immigration intégration on marche sur
deux jambes bien sûr que il faut de
l'intégration et donc il y a des mesures
sur l'apprentissage du français il y a
aussi des mesures sur les les
travailleurs pour répondre
spécifiquement sur les franç nousent
aujour sont bouleversés déjà par le
contexte international et par cet
attentat à nouveau quasiment jour pour
jour 3 ans après l'assassinat de Samuel
pati il y a un texte de loi il était
voilà très surveillé sur écoute avec un
pédigré familial vraiment proche de la
radicalisation islamiste on se dit
est-ce que ce texte de loi aurait permis
est-ce qu'il soit expulsé avant oui ou
non alors
ce qui est sûr c'est que dans le droit
actuel si vous êtes sur le territoire
national avant les 13 ans effectivement
vous pouvez vous relevez pas de
l'expulsion ça c'est un élément qui sera
levé pour autant il faut aussi dire les
choses clairement pour accompagner
quelqu'un dans son pays d'origine il
faut que vous ayez un laisser passer
consulaire ça ça relève de la
coopération internationale on peut pas
faire comme si ça n'existait pas mais
dans le texte aujourd'hui dans le dro
avant même de savoir si le pays
d'origine l'aurait repris il y a la
question de l'expulsion de son exécourui
l'expulsion vous avez deux cas vous avez
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
français qui est une mesure je prenais
moi-même quand j'étais sous-préfet une
mesure administrative mais qui derrière
en fait relève en fait quelque part de
la la bonne volonté sauf si vous allez
dans centre de rétention administrative
et puis ensuite il y a l'expulsion
judiciaire et effectivement
ce prévoit de faciliter par des mesures
administratives les mesures d'expulsion
et d'étendre le champ des mesures
d'ordre on va venir au texte mais il y a
malheureusement un contexteme si voilà
la loi doit être générale et imp
personnelle il y a un contexte Thomas
ménager Philiipe brin ce cette loi
permettrait d'empêcher aras est-ce qu'il
était possible d'empêcher aras avant
alors il y a un double mensonge de Géral
Rin premier c'est que l'article l631-3
du czda dispose
d'exceptionsch que le verrou des 13 ans
bien entendu il existe ça c'est une
réalité mais il y a des exceptions quand
il y a une atteinte au principes
fondamentaux une atteinte fondamentale à
la République quand il y a des cas en
lien avec le terroriste il y a la
possibilité d'enclencher des exceptions
à ce verrou il y avait aucune forme
d'infraction commise ou de fa d'indice
puisqu'il a été surveillé jusqu'à la
veille contrô mais il était au fsprt
depuis au fichier au fichier pour être
connu pour ses liens terroriste pour ces
liens de radicalisation donc la
radicalisation c'est atteintte aux
intérêts fondamentaux d'État à
rentrer qu'il n'a même pas essayé après
le deuxè mensonge de géraldin c'est de
dire que sa loi aurait pu changer
quelque chose parce que c'est une
réalité ce qui a été dit par Monsieur
marlex c'est que demain même s'il y a
une nouvelle loi le juge administratif
pourra utiliser un certain nombre de
traités notamment la CEDH et un certain
nombre de de grands
principes la Convention Européenne des
droit de l'homme pour refuser pour
rejeter ces demandes et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous proposons comme
euh les républicains qui sont venus sur
nos propositions je me rappelle quand
même que Monsieur Larché avait dit qu'il
avait voté Emmanuel Macron parce que
nous demandions de constitutionnaliser
le droit des étrangers nous proposons
que le droit des étrangers soit
supérieur à la CEDH pour éviter que des
juges décid à la place des politiques
décide en utilisant un certain nombre
voilà il ne s'agit pas de sortir de
l'état de droit pour aller sur la
question d'après mais de modifier l'état
de droit et de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse se protéger c'est pas la
convention c'est la Cour Européenne des
Droits de l'omme sa jurisprudence alors
on va essayer de comprendre Philippe
brin vous vous avez été dans les
tribunaux administratifs vous avez cité
deux exceptions à ce verrou des 13 ans
j'espère que ceux qui nous regardent
arrivent à suivre il y a une troisième
exception c'est si vous avez commis des
actes de provocation explicite et
délibéré la discrimination la haine ou
la violence sur une personne déterminée
c'est justement là-dessus sur les les
les coûts et la violence intrafamiliale
il s'agissait de sa mère qu'il y a eu
une garde à vue et en garde à vue à ce
moment-là c'est ce que dit le ministre
et bien avec cette nouvelle loi il
serait possible de le de l'expulser
alors que ce ne serait pas possible à
cause de la justice aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça la
vérité aujourd'hui c'est que moi
j'invite tout le monde à aller regarder
l'article
l631-3 du cza vous appz ça sur Google
vous allez sur le site legif France vous
voyez que on peut expulser quelqu'un qui
est arrivé en France avant l'âge de 13
ans s'il a des comportements de nature à
porter atteinte aux intérêts
fondamentaux de l'État liés à des
activités à caractère terroriste ou
constituant des actes de provocation
explicite et débéré à la discrimination
à la haine ou la violence viit alors
tout ça il faut le dire et moi je veux
vous dire là aussi vous pouvez regarder
la jurisprudence moi dans ma vie juge
administratif on a validé des expulsions
de personnes qui n'avaient pas été
condamné pour teror el gen de fait bah
pour des faits par exemple apologie
teroristme sur Facebook je dis je me
souviens très bien d'un dossier que j'is
traité mais vous pouvez regarder ça sur
les bases de jurisprudence vouses sur
Arian web c'est les bases de
jurisprudence du Conseil d'État vous
tapez quelques mots clés vous allez les
trouver moi on avz validé par exemple
dans mon tribunal l'expion un français
vous êtes un étranger en situation
irrégulière Vous faites l'apologie du
terrorisme sur Facebook en France on
peut vous
expulser cé pendant laaff semel pa à
l'époque j'étais en poste à monreuil on
avait expulsé un jeune qui avait fait
l'apologie de
la de la décapitation de Samuel paatti à
l'époque c'était en Égypte bon il était
arrivé avant l'âge de 13 ans donc autant
donc tout ça pour vous dire que le débat
sur droit des étrangers mérite mieux que
des postures et de nouvelles lois on a
eu beaucoup beaucoup de lois sur droit
étrangers on a une trentaine de lois sur
les 30 dernières années donc on a chaque
année une réforme de droit des étrangers
donc moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut
mettre les moyens en place qu'est-ce qui
se passe la vérité c'est que quand on
fait 150000 obligations de quitter le
territoire français évidemment qu'on les
exécute pas on a besoin aujourd'hui
alors attendez est-ce que vous pouvez
nous c'est on parle d'expulsion parce
que là il faut qu'on soit bien clair on
parle d'expulsion on parle deqtfqtf
c'est administratif c'est pour
l'irrégularité du séjour ça n pas la
même chose que les expulion le qtf c'est
une mesure d'expulsion après elles ne
sont pas exécuté c'est une obligation de
quitter le territoire franç n'est pas
judiciaire qui est administra mais elle
est quand même on peut quand même
l'exécuter c'est qu' y a plein def qui
sont exécuté bien sûr mais vous n'êtes
pas forcément dans dans une situation de
trouble à l'ordre public simplement
public vous avez l'obligation de quitter
le tritoire français et l'État peut à
tout moment vous mettre dans un avion et
vous renvoyer chez vous je je veux le
dire ici il y a je crois beaucoup de
démagogie et beaucoup j'ai envie de dire
de raccourcis qui sont fait aujourd'hui
le problème c'est pas notre cadre
juridique j'en parlais encore tout à
l'heure avec le préfet de mon
département le problème ce sont les
moyens qu'on doit mettre en place pour
notamment expulser les personnes les
plus dangereuses sur le territoire
national alors où ces moyens précisément
alors moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut par exemple avoir les effectifs
suffisants police aux frontières ils ont
été réduit de 20 % durant les 5
dernières années on a des grandes
difficultés par exemple aujourd'hui dans
la programmation des vols c'est une
réalité très concrète mais je veux le
dire ici parce que c'est ça aujourd'hui
la question vous avez un sous-préfet
comme monsieur mournet qui voit que dans
l'arrondissement dont il a la charge il
a un fichier est un fichier s pardon
particulièrement dangereux qu'il faut
l'expulser juridiquement ça colle il
fait l'action et puis la PAF va aller
l'appréhender on va le mettre au centre
de rétention administrative et puis pour
des raisons de bureaucratie
administrative de dysfonctionnement du
ministère de l'Intérieur le vol ne va
pas être mise pas être programmé et il
va Pasir de ai parce qu'il n'y a pas
forcément le pays à l'arrivée ou à
l'origine quiac la question en plus des
laisser passer consulair il faut le
rappeler 1er semestre 2021 par exemple
il y a 9800 au qtf donc obligation de
quitter le territoire français à
destination de l'Algérie 28 laisser
passer consulaair délivré c'està dire
qu'il y a que 28 autorisations de faire
atterrir les avions pour avec les
étrangers dans problème final ce sont
les laiss passer consul avec les pays du
Magre le cœur du débat il est là mais je
voudrais juste recituer une chose
euh la personne qui a commis le
l'attentat le dernier attentat il est
fiché s euh fich S c'est pas seulement
pour de la maltraitance vis-à-vis de sa
maman je suis désolé bien sû euh parce
il y a un terreau voilà il y a un
terreot familial le père a été expulsé
il y a quelques années le frère est
condamné est en prison justement et on
sait très bien qu'il y a des lien très
très proche avec le djihadismeme donc à
partir de là s'il est fiché s
normalement et effectivement quel que
soit son âge d'entrée sur le territoire
on peut dans des circonstances
particulières le renvoyer le problème
c'est il est chechenen d'origine aller
avoir un passeport enfin un visa pour le
retour en tchenéie c'est ça le vrai
sujet le le le le cont tenu du contexte
avec la Russie il y a un problème à ce
niveau-là mais moi quand j'entends mes
collègues parlerit des des obligations
de quitter le territoire français
combien sont exécutés aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire que on prononce énormément
de mesures pour des personnes qu'on
voudrait voir quitter notre territoire
ils ne sont pas en situation régulière
sur alors j'ai les chi si vous voulez
pour 2020 c'était une année covid donc
seulement 6 % 6,9 presque 7 % norm et on
peut arriver aux meilleures années
autour de 20 % c'est bien moins qu'en
Allemagne NOTAM on était plutôt à 11 %
donc voilà la réalité c'est que vous
pouvez délivrer des obligations de
quitter territoire français mais que
quand seulement 11 % sont appliqués je
trouve queil y a une telle disproportion
et ça c'est le vrai les raisons
principales est-ce que c'est le problème
des laisser passer consulaires on a
parlé de ces pays ou c'est tout
simplement les recours contre ces
décisions de de quitter le les délais de
recours des avocats en drroit des
étrangers qui sont dans leur droit à
défendre ces personnes et qui joue sur
les délais ou vous avez les deux il faut
aussi si on compare avec l'Allemagne
compar ce qui est comparable l'Allemagne
fait beaucoup moins d'octf dans la
pratique dans dans la pratique française
c'est presque devenu un un document de
de de non régularité donc peut-être que
on fait proportionnellement beaucoup de
qtf par rapport effectivement à
l'effectivité mais il y a deux sujets on
peut pas le contourner le sujet que
quand vous mettez quelqu'un en centre de
rétention administrative il faut
derrière c'est une mesure administrative
c'est pas une mesure du du juge euh il
faut pouvoir effectivement
leuraccompagner alors avoir des sujets
de programmation des vols mais quand
même moi je veux rendre hommage aux
gendarmes et aux policiers aux
frontières qui travaillent le cœur de
l'affaire c'est la coopération
internationale et c'est effectivement
l'office du juge qui doit être accéléré
je voudrais signaler quand même que ce
projet de loi a été intégralement vous
le savez validé par le Conseil d'État
parce qu'on on facilite l'office du juge
on l'ordre républicain n' n'a évidemment
aucune autre possibilité d'exister que
dans un état de droit mais il y a des
mesures de fermeté sur les expulions que
nous prenons dans ce texte
tion sont nomuses on a parlé destf et
faciliter les les expulsions c'est aussi
l'objectif de de ce projet de loi
explication avec lesos et je vous
redonne la parole juste
après une nouvelle loi pour en finir
avec les limites de la législation
actuelle c'est le souhait de Gérald
Haran aujourd'hui il y a 4000 cas comme
celui-ci où le ministreintérieur
voudrait les expulser et la loi ne le
peut pas on protège tous les gens qui
sont arrivés avant l'âge de 13 ans sur
le territoire national cette loi est
absurde il faut la changer c'est
d'ailleurs le cœur même du texte que je
propose au parlementaires dans la loi
immigration aujourd'hui des protections
existent pour les étrangers menacés
d'expulsion pour des actes de
délinquence ou de non respect des
valeurs de la République il suffit
notamment d'être arrivé avant 13 ans
d'avoir un enfant ou d'être marié avec
un français actuellement ces protections
peuvent déjà être levées de façon
exceptionnelle en cas d'atteinte aux
intérêts fondamentaux de l'État
d'activités terroriste ou de provocation
à la discrimination la haine ou la
violence le projet de loi immigration
veut aller plus loin un étranger
condamné pour des crimes ou deslit punis
de 10 ans ou plus d'emprisonnement
pourra désormais être expulsé le
ministre ajoute même que l'expulsion
pourra être prononcée sans attendre la
décision de justice quelqu'un qui aurait
violenté sa femme quelqu'un qui aurait
attaqué un policier quelqu'un qui aurait
fait un trafic de drogue qui aurait été
en garde à vue c'est avant même
d'attendre la condamnation s'il enct la
peine de je peux obtenir son expulsion
de même le projet lois ouvre la porte à
une sorte de double peine à la discrtion
du juge dans le cas des OQTF les
obligations de quitter le territoire
français ces verrou pourront aussi être
levés en cas de comportement
représentant une menace grave pour
l'ordre public reste un problème celui
de l'application de ces disposition seul
7 % des otf ont abouti au premier
semestre
2022 et nous sommes à distance avec
Pascal Briss l'ancien directeur de
l'OFPRA qui est aujourd'hui président de
la Fédération des acteurs de la
solidarité bonsoir
Pascal Briss le texte de Géral Darmanin
on on vient de le comprendre nous dit en
substance qu'il n'y a plus besoin d'une
décision de justice si un étranger en
situation irrégulière est poursuivi pour
une infraction passive de 10 ans 5 ans
si c'est une récidive il pourra être
expulsé que pensez-vous de cette
mesure il faut expulser ces personnes
qui n'ont rien à faire sur le territoire
national parce qu'elle constiue une
menace terroriste ou parce que elles
onit commise des actes euh extrêmement
lourd disant c'est extrêmement lourd euh
ça a été dit dans votre débat dès
aujourd'hui lorsque les personnes
constituent une menace terroriste ils
sont expulsables et ils doivent être
expulsés euh et quand a des peines de de
de de de 10 ans il me semble en revanche
que il faut absolument qu'il y ait une
condamnation par un juge parce que sinon
on voit bien que du point de vue du
fonctionnement de l'État de droit on
entre dans des zones incontrôlables et
il doit être possible de respecter cela
tout en faisant preuve d'une fermeté
absolue c'est que ces personnes doivent
effectivement être expulsées le ministre
explique que s'il faut attendre la
décision de condamnation du juge et bien
la personne peut passer à l'acte et
avoir d'autres voilà assassinat et et
d'autres victimes en France qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ce à ce yatus du
temps finalement
oui mais vous voyez et je comprends tout
à fait le préoccupation du ministre
lorsque j'étais directeur de l'OF pr où
j'ai obtenu vous le savez en 2015 qu'on
a introduiseent dans la loi des
dispositions qui n'existaient pas qui
permettaient de faire tomber des statuts
de réfugiés pour expulser des gens qui
constituaient une menace terroriste j'ai
vécu tout cela rien n'est simple dans
ces domainesl mais l'important c'est
effectivement que et l'intérieur les
services du ministère de l'Intérieur et
les services du ministère de la Justice
puissent concentrer tous leurs efforts
de manière à ce que ces personnes-là qui
constituent une menace terroristes soit
effectivement expulsés plutôt que on les
mobilise sur par exemple de très
nombreuses ocut hord d'expulsion pour
des étrangers qui ne demandent qu'à
travailler qui ne posent aucun problème
d'ordre public empêchant les services du
ministère de l'Intérieur et les juges de
faire leur travail de manière à ce que
ces gens soient expulsés mais encore une
fois vous ne pouvez pas dans un état de
droit mais ce sera l'appréciation du
gouvernement du Parlement et du Conseil
constitutionnel décider l'expulsion de
quelqu'un sans qu'un juge les décidé h
dernière question rapidement Pascal BR
le rétablissement de la la double peine
c'est prévu aussi dans le texte ulsion
en cas de condamnation pénale on sait
que la prison est un vecteur de
radicalisation est-ce que ça permet de
nous protéger de la menace islamiste
vous savez dans dans ces débats moi je
me méfie des mots valises qui tout de
suite
empêche de réfléchir encore une fois
expulser celles et ceux qui constituent
une menace terroriste celles et ceux qui
ont commis des crimes lourds c'est
indispensable si ça doit être fait
immédiatement après la condamnation ou
immédiatement la sortie de prison moi ça
ne me pose aucun probl problème mais je
voudrais insister sur deux points encore
une fois un pour cela il faut que les
préfets puissent concentrer tous leurs
moyens contre cette action là et non à
gâcher la vie de gens qui demandent àà
travailler de je voudrais y insister on
n pas le droit de donner raison aux
assassins et aux terroristes l'accueil
maîtrisé organisé il était indispensable
avant l'assassinat de cet enseignant il
reste indispensable aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire à la fois faire preuve de
la plus grande fermeté contre les
assassins et les terroristes et faire en
sorte que les hommes et les femmes
étrangères dans ce pays qui peuvent et
veulent travailler puissent le faire via
la régularisation ça nous ramène
déjouons les les les le piège tendu par
les terroristes merci beaucoup Pascal
bris de nous avoir accordé ces ses
réponses en direct Thomas ménager c'est
l'ancien directeur de l'OFPRA qui dit
attention à l'état de droit le juge doit
rester celui qui décide qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à cela on dit pas le
contraire absolument pas mais vous savez
l'État de droit c'est aussi au peuple ou
ses représentants de modifier un certain
nombre de règles pour que l'État de
droit soit suffisamment ferme soit
suffisamment doté pour vous voulez
renvoyer tous les fichiers s étrangers
dans leur pays comment vous faites ça
concrètement mais aujourd'hui il y a un
certain nombre de cas comme je on l'a
dit à l'instant et ça a été dit très
clairement on peut le faire il y a un
manque de volonté politique je veux
rebondir sur les laissé passer consula
c'est un vrai sujet alors déjà sur le
cas du du du de de cet attentat et de de
cette ce terroriste qui a ôté la vie à
ce professeur il était fiché pas fich S
mais au fsprt depuis c'est au fichier de
radicalisation depuis 2021 donc bien
avant la guerre en Ukraine et bien avant
les relations que nous pouvons avoir
aujourd'hui avec la Russie ça je tiens à
le dire faut quand même pas l'ou on
aurait pu on aurait pu entamer alors il
y aurait la question des délais bien
entendu et ça on est d'accord sur le
fait d'accélérer les procédures puisque
c'est une vraie problématique mais
aujourd'hui sur les laisser passer
consul il y a aussi un besoin de volonté
politique et de diplomatie on peut bien
entendu stopper les transferts de fonds
de la diaspora on peut refuser les
demandes de visa notamment d'un certain
nombre de dirigeants de pays qui
viennent se soigner à Paris et qui ont
besoin de visa on peut stopper l'aide au
développement mon collègue citait
l'Algérie 279 millions versés à
l'Algérie par l'Union européenne on peut
faire un certain nombre de mesures on
peut remettre en cause aussi l'accord de
68 avec l'Algérie qui facilite l'arrivée
d'un certain nombre d'Algériens sur
notre sol à un moment c'est une question
volonté politique on peut pas se laisser
dicter notre politique migratoire qui il
y a sur notre sol qui se maintient par
des pays vous maintenez votre réforme de
la Constitution qui vous permet de
reprendre le contrôle migratoire sur
leur des
traités je vous entends pas en parler je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure nous nous
souhaitons avec Marie Le Pen nous
souhaitons un référendum nous souhaitons
que les Français puissent s'exprimer et
nous souhaitons que via ce référendum le
droit des étrangers soit
constitutionnalisé et donc pour éviter
un certain nombre de cas mais qui n'est
pas l'excuse à à toutes les
problématiques que nous connaissons
actuellement mais qui peut s'avérer être
un cas pour que le juge administratif
n'ordonne pas l'expulsion d'un certain
nombre d'étrangers ce qui n'est pas le
cas en l'occurrence puisque là on est
dans le casadre d'un d'un fait de
terroriste comme ça a été dit et il y
aurait eu de fortes chances si ça avait
été lancé par le ministère de
l'Intérieur que le jeune administratif
donne suite à l'expulsion et n'utilise
pas d'autres raisons Philip brin quand
on regarde ces questions d'imération
dans l'opinion quand on regarde les
sondages de Marine Le Pen il y a une
attente très clair qu'est-ce que vous
répondez aux propositions du
rassemblement national sondage en entier
par exemple il y a une majorité de
Français qui sont favorables à ce qu'on
régularise tous les étrangers qui
travaillent ce qui est très différent de
ce que propose le rassemblement national
rassemblement national je dis encore une
fois la question qu' fa la question ce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
arrive à reconduire effectivement les
gens qui représentent un danger pour
notre pays on a tous les moyens
juridiques aujourd'hui pour le faire
alors évidemment c'est pas un propos
d'estrade de dire qu'il y a des
problèmes de bureaucratie dans
l'administration française c'est plus
simple de dire on va modifier la
Constitution on va sortir d'un traité
les juges c'est tous des juges au
développement en
Algérie non non mais donc aujourd'hui il
y a un vrai problème administratif
pardon de le dire mais mais soyons dans
la vérité le goût de la vérité le goût
de dire qu'on a un problème
administratif dans l'organisation
aujourd'hui des reconduites qui est
chaotique qui est chaotique et moi je
crois que c'est pas une bonne idée
aujourd'hui de délivrer 130000 140000
bientôt 150000 obligations de quitter
les territoir français parant on n pas
les moyens de les exécuter qu policiers
et gendarmes par personne pour les
expulser à la question c'est l'article 3
de la régularisation pour les métiers en
tension aujourd'hui donc je je vois où
vous voulez aller expulser ceux qui nous
menacent et régulariser ceux qui même
irrégulier travaillent déjà il y a des
il y a des besoins à ce stade jeis vous
faire réagir sur la dernière partie de
ce Ce débataimerais à votre regard euh
voilà le le djihadisme d'atmosphère la
lutte contre l'islamisme on voit bien
que ça n'est pas qu'une question de
texte de loi on voit bien que c'est un
combat culturel presque certains disent
même civilisationnel à l'heure des
réseaux sociaux est-ce que nos
démocraties on on ont les
moyens je ne sais pas si on en a les
moyens mais en tout cas on on on on peut
agir il y a quand même des choses à
faire j'entends par exemple très souvent
dire d'ailleurs de de la part de tous
les partis de droite de gauche oui ça
suffit l'empilement des réformes ça
suffit l'empilement des mois je trouve
que c'est une réaction absurde en fait
le monde change autour de nous en
permanence et on a en plus toujours un
train de retard notamment sur cette
question de de islamisme et du
terrorisme donc on est obligé de trouver
des moyens de s'adapter aux nouvelles
menaces et donc évidemment on doit avoir
recours donc on doit pas accepter une
part d'impuissance 40 attentats déjoués
c'est énorme c'est déjà tout il faut pas
de fatalisme maintenant sur cette
question proprement dite euh oui bien
sûr qu'il faut expliquer il faut
expulser les gens qui nous menacent qui
menacent la société et qui même
diffusent des idées qui sont nos et à
bond pour utiliser un mot très galvodé
mais en tout cas qui participe aux
menaces que que nous subissons le
problème c'est c'est vers où les pays
d'origine en général n'en veulent pas et
les autres encore moins donc on se
trouvera toujours à buter sur cette
question là quelle que soit la volonté
politique pour terminer ce ce débat
Benoît mournaet on parlait avec Philippe
brin au fond d'arrêter des otf qui de
toute façon ne sont pas bien exécutés il
y a des demandes des besoins dans les
restaurants dans le bâtiment dans les
hôtel est-ce que avec ce contexte vous
maintenez ce volet régularisation oui
absolument moi en écoutant mon collègue
du Parti socialiste et ma collègue des
républicains j'espère bien qu'ils vont
voter ce texte qui fonctionne sur deux
jambes effectivement il y a des mesures
de fermeté il y a des éléments
d'application qui aujourd'hui sont des
réserves d'ordre public qu'il faut lever
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit qui existent
demain un étranger qui commet des qui se
met en infraction avec la loi même si
Mar s'il est marié avec une française
pourra être reconduit mais d'un autre
côté vous avez des gens qui sont dans un
nainel juridique qui ont des au qtf mais
qui sont pas effectivement qui ont pas
été exécutés et qui auraient qu'un
traitement social non il faut leur
permettre de travailler pour leur
permettre de vivre et de s'intégrer on
fonctionne sur ces deux jambes il
faudrait pas que les travailleurs
subissent les les pot cassés des
délinquant et pas qu' pour terminer je
vais vous montrer dans l'état actuel des
choses en 2022 il y a eu plus 17,2 %
d'autorisation de titre de séjour
supplémentaire ce qui veut dire que le
problème de l'emploi pour les gens qui
ont envie de travailler qui arrivent sur
notre territoire et qui on envie
travailler ne se pose pas mais en
parallèle et ça je voudrais qu'on ait
une pensée aussi pour toutes ces
familles 273 victime du terrorisme en
France c'est colossal le chiffre est est
est tellement habysal que ça ça laisse
pour vous ce cet attentat d'aras
nécessite d'abandonner le volet
régularisation je vous je vais vous
donner une la vraie raison il y a
aujourd'hui en France effectivement
500000 étrangers sans emploi mais il y a
en parallèle 1400000 jeunes qui on la
nationalité française quelle que soit
leur origine qui sont sans emploi et il
y a 3 millions de chômeurs donc si
vraiment on veut s'attaquer à l'emploi
il y a d'autres façons de le faire que
de créer cet appel d'air et je pense que
là main dans le texte on sait pas parce
une ligne rouge ça veut dire 493 ça veut
dire motion de censure ça veut dire
493 je ne serais pas je ne suis je ne
sais pas je ne vais pas prendre la
décision exp votre du bâtiment ou au
service à la personne ou ou à
l'agriculture parce qu'il y a quand même
des métiers en tenstion objectivement il
y a des métiers en tenstion mais
justement avec le nombre de chômeurs
avec 3 millions de chômeurs on doit
pouvoir réinsérer ces personnesl bien on
s'arrête là on voit bien que le débat ne
fait commencer pas d'accord merci à vous
on voit que le calendrier législatif
s'accélère ça part au Sénat début
novembre et puis à l'Assemblée dans la
foulée merci à vous vous restez avec moi
Michell brazan dans une dizaine de
minutes les partis pris de nos
affranchis ce soir l'économie avec Fanny
guinochet de la tribune dimanche et de
France Info attention la prime Macron va
coûter plus cher à ce qui l'aperçoivent
et ceux qui la payent et puis carte
blanche ce soir ayanis roder après
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard 3 ans
après celui de Samuel pati et puis
elsamondin Gava de quoi nous parlez-vous
ce soir écouté moratoire clarification
rupture on va s'interroger est-ce la fin
de la nupesse voilà on verra ça dans
Bourbon express à tout à l'heure les
amis mais d'abord on va s'intéresser un
peu plus de plus près au ramass grâce à
vous michaell Prazan vous avez
longuement enquêté c'était en 2013 sur
les Frères musulmans dont le ramass je
le disais est une mation vous avez
rencontré ses chefs à Gaza et au Ker sa
stratégie ses buts sa vision du monde on
voit ça dans l'invitation d'élè Bonduel
on en parle tous les deux juste
après si on vous invite Michel prasan
c'est pour comprendre quel est le
fonctionnement du ramas ce mouvement
islamiste radical quel est son
terro le ramas à la fois soutenu par
l'Iran les chiides du hebollah est
directement issu de la galaxie des
Frères
musulmans journalistes documentaristes
auteurs vous avez un œil expert sur ces
mouvements radicaux à travers vos
nombreux ouvrages vous enquêtez sur
l'antisémitisme le terrorisme et vous
avez notamment signé en 2013 ce
documentaire très fouillé sur
l'ascension de la confréie des Frères
musulmans quelle société propose-t-il au
juste la réponse se trouve dans son
manifeste en 50 points publié en
1936 le programme politique de la
confrerie il y dessine les contours d'un
nouveau totalitarisme une théocratie
gouvernée par la loi islamique la
charia
interdire surveiller punir en sont les
maîtres mot vous décortiquez cette
organisation sunnite berceau de l'islam
politique créée en Égypte à la fin des
années 20 et vous explorer ses
ramifications à travers le monde vous
dissquez notamment la propagande de sa
branche
l'organisation terroriste au centre du
conflit
israloestinien il n'y a pas que dans les
programmes pour enfants de la chî que
sonton discours de ha àre des
juif la bille territoriale ou la
compétition
religieuse ils sont aussi ten par les
représentants du bureau de la guidance
au le ramas né dans la foulée de la
première in en 87 un mouvement qui dans
sa charte prône la destruction de l'État
d'Israël et refuse le partage de la
Palestine c'est sa branche armée qui a
perpétré les massacres d'il y a 10 jours
en Israël alors Michell prasant nous
avons une question pour vous le Hamas
sert-il encore la cause
palestinienne réponse Michel prasan Le
ramas a toujours desservi la cause
palestinienne en aucun cas il ne l'a
servi d'ailleurs j'entends souvent dire
que c'est un mouvement nationaliste
palestinien ou autres ça n'est pas du
tout un mouvement
nationaliste le nationalisme arabe et
d'ailleurs dont d'une certaine manière
les tenants de l'OLP c'est-à-dire
l'Autorité palestinienne qui lui est
authentiquement un mouvement
nationaliste même s'il a les mêmes
racines il vient aussi des Frères
musulmans mais de manière plus lointaine
et puis il a beaucoup évolué mais le
ramass c'est un mouvement islamiste
avant tout c'est un mouvement islamiste
ce qu'il veut c'est comme tous les
mouvements islamistes et donc comme le
veut évidemment la doxa frériste des
Frères musulmans c'est dans un premier
temps rétablir le califat islamique qui
évidemment pour cette visionl du monde
et de cette région du monde Israël est
une pustule insupportable et à terme à
très très long terme il s'agit
évidemment de souscrire disons à leur
lecture très particulière de l'islam qui
est que voilà il ne doit pas rester 1 m
car de terre sur la planète qui ne soit
pas qui ne reconnaissent pas la vérité
de l'islam et donc à terme c'est
l'islamisation du monde mais en tout cas
dans un premier moyen terme il s'agit de
reconstituer le califat islamique et
pour se faire évidemment détruire Israël
donc pour vous cette cause palestinienne
est serv à des fins islamistes bien plus
que national le ramas a déjà fait de
nombreux attentats en Israël il a déjà
kidnappé des otages sauf que là c'est
très différent dans le mode opératoire
que ce soit dans les kibuts à hhkelon
àderot on est dans autre chose on est
dans des poromes à grande échelle les
terroristes se sont acharnés sur les
corps et beniamine netaniaou dit le
ramas c'est daesh est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça écoutez j'ai j'ai
évoqué les Frères musulmans nés en 1928
euh c'est le pilier euh à partir de là
le ramas c'est euh disons le frère
choyer des Frères musulmans euh ils sont
frères musulmans de même d'ailleurs que
le Djihad islamique mais qui se
revendique aussi euh l'autre
organisation euh l'autre organisation
tolérée parce que frériste à Gaza sinon
elle ne serait pas hein le ramas règne
sur ce territoire d'une main de fer
totalement insupportable d'ailleurs on
va y venir euh donc il y a cette
centralité des frè musulmans les Frères
musulmans sont aujourd'hui présents dans
80 82 pays de par le monde et l'une des
premières antennes c'est évidemment
d'abord l'antenne syrienne et puis
ensuite l'antenne palestinienne qui date
contrairement à ce qu'on dit j'entends
toujours dire que le ramas est né en 87
88 c'est le nom qui est né en 87 88 les
Frères musulmans sont présents depuis
1930 et la création des Frères musulmans
en Égypte c'est 1928 donc c'est très
rapide et la question palestinienne est
devenue une question fédératriste et
centrale pour la confréie par ailleurs
Al-Qaïda est né au sein de la confréerie
et puis daesh est une extension ou une
métastase d'Al-Qaïda donc évidemment
tout ça est continuum il y a eu des
manifestations à Gaza cet été contre le
ramasse vite réprimé c'était évidemment
avant les massacres du 7 octobre il y a
pas eu d'élection hein du ramas depuis
2008 qu'est-ce qu'on sait des
populations civile par rapport à leur
chef est-ce qu'ils soutiennent le
ramasse ou est-ce qu'ils en sont les
otages c'est absolument impossible à
dire c'est sans doute un peu des
deux les gens sont vraiment mis sous
surveillance et puis vous savez il y a
toujours une suspicion qui rne dans la
population parce que votre voisin si
vous dites un mot de trop peut
l'entendre peut vous dénoncer on est
dans ce type d'atmosphère on est dans ce
type de régime et d'une certaine manière
cette suspicion généralisée ne permet
pas aux gens de s'exprimer librement et
donc ne nous permet pas de sonder la rue
ou la société
palestinienne on a aujourd'hui ils sont
là depuis voyez ils ont pris ce
territoire au milieu des années 2000
donc aujourd'hui ils ne souffrent plus
depuis très longtemps d'ailleurs
d'aucune contestation et ils ont réussi
vous en avez eu un extrait dans alaxa
Télé à TV on appelle au meurtrre et on
conditionne les enfants palestiniens au
meurtrre dès leur plus jeune âge donc il
il y a ils ont réussi tout de même à
imprégner une forme d'idéologie leur
idéologie sur la population à quel point
la population y adhère c'est très très
difficile à dire mais même si elle n'y
ad même si elle n'y adhère pas ça le
plus inquiétant c'est que l'OLP disons
l'Autorité palestinienne est tellement
discréditée et je pense que le le ramas
l'est aussi de manière majoritaire au
sein de la population mais ils ne vont
pas nécessairement se tourner vers la
démocratie lorsque j'étais à Gaza j'ai
sondé ce que je pouvais sonder et
notamment via des journalistes présents
sur place qui sont Palestiniens et qui
m'expliquaient qu'aujourd'hui le combat
du Hamas ce livre non pas contre
l'autorité palestinienne non pas contre
un mouvement clandestin démocrate mais
contre Al-Qaïda qui était très implanté
dans C ce territoire là et il me disait
que s'il y avait des des élections
libres ce serait sans doute alkaaïda qui
remportera donc on est sur un terrain
islamiste fertile comment expliquer que
le chef historique ma à nié ne soit pas
à Gaza il est au Qatar à DOA alors que
l'opération terrestre se prépare et que
son peuple est en danger ben c'est comme
les grands généraux de la Première
Guerre mondiale voilà on envoie les gens
au caspip et si possible la population
est utilisée pour servir de boucliers
humain mais les chefs eux sont à l'abri
dans des hôtels de luxe au Qatar la
cause palestinienne on on l' vu dans
votre film on le voit évidemment jour
après jour dans le monde avec les
manifestations c'est un puissant
fédérateur dans le monde musulman je
vais vous montrer des images Mossou en
Irak Raba au Maroc mais aussi en
Occident hein beaucoup de manifestations
en soutien à la population palestinienne
avant cette intervention terrestre qui
sera de fait très meurtrière de part et
d'autres c'est pour ça que le le RAM
c'est soutenu aussi par l'Iran chiite
c'est ce puissant fédérateur qui est la
cause palestinienne qui fait qu'on a un
ramasse sunnite soutenu par l'Iran chiit
expliquez-nous ça c'est l'une des
raisons et en même temps c'est l'une des
explications aussi euh en
1953 il y a la Conférence islamique qui
est organisée par les Frères musulmans
euh à Jérusalem qui à l'époque est
encore sous domination jordanienne et
ils vont inviter un groupe le chef d'un
groupe terroriste iranien qui s'appelle
navap safawi qui partage beaucoup de
leur idéologie donc il va y avoir ce
rapprochement et les Frères musulmans à
l'époque comprennent que Israël est un
problème mais il n'arrive pas très bien
à savoir comment le prendre et comment
diffuser au fond sa volonté de de
destruction la volonté de destruction de
l'État d'Israël et navoapsafaoui
l'Iranien chiite va déclarer Israël la
l'antité sioniste comme il
l'appelle n'est pas qu'une question de
voisinage c'est pas une
question purement arabe c'est une
question qui concerne l'UMA l'ensemble
des musulmans et ça ça va être une
révélation et à partir de là les
PAL ce que va dir le khamas c'est-à-dire
les Frères musulmans d'abord égyptiens
et ensuite Palestiniens vont déclarer
mais c'est de manière totalement
performative le territoire comme étant
un wakf c'est-à-dire un bien sacré de
l'islam moi je peux décréter que ce
studio est un wakf et à ce moment-là je
tuerai n'importe qui qui va y entrer
mais c'est une déclaration performative
qui va être en fait légalisé par les
imames par voilà et à partir de là et
bien évidemment puisque c'est un bien
sacré tous les coups sont permis pour en
venir à bout alors on comprend cette
cette jonction qui est un peu contre
nature dans l'islam sunnite et chiite il
y a une chose rare une image que je
voulais vous montrer une manifestation à
Tan Holland des massacres on est le 8
octobre des Iraniens écoutz qui refusent
d'être instrumentalisés sur le dos des
Palestiniens
[Applaudissements]
écoutez voilà ces images elles ont fait
le tour du monde on est à Tran match de
foot et on connaît la répression des
Molas on a des Iraniens de Tran qui
disent non tu ne vas pas
m'instrumentaliser je serais pas aussi
vulgaire que ce que disent ces
supporters avec ton drapeau palestinien
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire que c'est
un espoir
euh les Iraniens n'ont pas de traditions
très anciennes
d'antisémitisme par ailleurs les gens
les Iraniens ont un niveau d'éducation
bien supérieur à celui qu'on peut
trouver à Gaza et dans certains de ces
territoires là ils ne sont pas idiots
ils sont connectés ils n'en peuvent plus
de ce régime démol là mais attention ces
imagesl nous viennent de Teran euh il y
a une bourgeoisie à Teran qui vit plutôt
finalement à l'heure occidentale qu'à
l'URE moyenneorientale mais que sait-on
au juste du reste de la population que
son que sait-on au juste des campagnes
iraniennes à mon avis on est dans une
situation un peu à l'anatolienne pour la
Russie pour la pour la Turquie pardon
euh où il est très difficile au fond
d'associer ces populations orientales de
la Turquie à une population plus
occidentalisé et je pense qu'on est à
peu près dans la même situation en Iran
que redoutez-vous le plus de l'opération
terrestre les Israéliens sont-ils
capables à votre avis de respecter le le
droit international de la guerre après
ce qui leur est arrivé c'est très
difficile à dire je pense que à juste
raison les Israéliens veulent en finir
avec le Rama c'est une menace
extrêmement sérieuse et ça nous l'a été
démontré ces derni aucune chance que les
Gazaoui passent un corridor vers
l'Égypte via la frontière sud de Gaza
via Rafa pourquoi les Égyptiens refusent
d'un mot alors les Égyptiens refusent
parce qu'ils ont pas tellement envie de
se retrouver avec 2 millions de
Palestiniens sur leur
territoire qui plisait en
emprint de cette idéologie
frériste que Aliss au pouvoir en Égypte
a
renversé lorsque Mohamed Morsy qui était
le dirigeant de la confréie en Égypte
avait pris le pouvoir et avait mené le
pays dans le chao le plus total
donc je crois qu'il est très soucieux de
l'intégrité de son pouvoir c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire et il ne veut
pas être à nouveau confronté à des
situations de déstabilisation extrême
voilà on va suivre ça avec attention
merci beaucoup Michel prasent merci pour
ce décryptage important je renvoie votre
film qui est d'ailleurs disponible sur
le réseau daily motion on peut le voir
sur les Frères musulmans et et qui
montre aussi à quel point le réseau
frériste est infiltré et présent avec
ses relais en France on on pourrait en
parler longtemps vous restez avec moi
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti prix ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueil tout de
suite bonsoir les
affranchis Yanis roder à qui on a
demandé une carte blanche après
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard on
vous connaît bien professeur d'histoire
géographie à Saint-Denis et Fanny
guinochet pour l'économie la tribune
dimanche ce nouveau journal que nous
supportons et bien sûr France Info
commence par Bourbon Express l'histoire
du jour c'est vous qui nous la raconte à
l'Assemblée els minava oui et ce n'est
pas une aème chronique sur les tensions
à la nupes là on s proche de la fin plus
les journées passent plus ces tensions
semblent s'exacerber je vais vous faire
un peu le film dans l'ordre ce weekend
on a une décision tranchée de la part
des communistes pour le parti de Fabien
Roussel et bien la nupess est dans une
impasse je me suis adressé aux
dirigeants de la France insoumise pour
leur dire pour leur dire que ça ne
pouvait pas continuer comme ça ni les UL
ni l'impossibilité pour eux de qualifier
d'organisation terroriste le Hamas tant
qu'il n'y avait pas une clarification
sur ces sujets important nous ne pouvons
pas continuer à travailler ensemble et
nous rompons donc toute relation pour
les socialistes cette fois Olivier fort
le premier secrétaire annonce ce matin
un moratoire une suspension des travaux
d'ailleurs le groupe n'était pas présent
à la réunion intergroupe du mardi matin
et le PS cible nommément un homme
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a aujourd
aujourd'hui un sujet avec la méthode
Mélenchon parce que effectivement il
conduit la gauche dans une
forme de stagnation et à un moment au
contraire il faudrait qu'elle reprenne
son élan c'est une rupture oui ou non il
y a aujourd'hui moi je proposerai ce
soir au socialiste un
moratoire le Conseil national doit
valider cette décision de moratoire
certains députés socialistes veulent
enlever toute référence à la nupesse
dans le nom du groupe c'est symbolique
mais c'est pour montrer quand même leur
opposition les écologistes ils ont
envoyé une lettre aux 151 députés de la
nupes pour appeler au sursaut au sursaut
pour éviter le chaos et l'attention est
encore montée d'un cran si on pouvait
encore monter encore plus avec les
déclarations de danielono ouais la
députée insoumise était sur Sud Radio ce
matin et elle a dit cela c'est un groupe
politique islamiste qui a une branche
armée et qui s'inscrit dans les
formations politiques
palestiniennes a pour objectif la
libérration c'est un mouvement de
résistance qui résiste à une occupation
c'est un mouvement de résistance oui
elle était interrogé donc sur le Hamas
vous en parliez les insoumis en
conférence de presse quelques minutes
plus tard ils ne se sont pas
désolidarisés de ses propos même si au
détour d'une phrase un député a quand
même précisé que le Hamas n'était pas un
mouvement de résistance n'empêche que
ces propos de Daniel auonau ils ont
déclenché un tolé chez les partenaires
des insoumis mais aussi des critiques en
interne écoutez Raquel garido le mieux
ce serait que que notre collègue Daniel
obono retire ses propos ce serait le
mieux ses propos ne reflètent pas ce que
nous sommes ce que nous pensons personne
dans le groupe considère que le Hamas
est une organisation de résistance alors
on sait que l'ancienne avocat est pas en
odeur de sainteté avec la direction mais
en tout cas ça tangue à la nupesse et ça
tangue aussi chez les insoumis alors
est-ce que la nuupe est morte ou elle
bouge encore bah c'est la question que
tout le monde a posé on comprend pas
vraiment en fait la vérité c'est que
personne veut déclarer la nuupesse morte
puisque personne ne veut déclarer la
mort de l'espoir de l'union de la gauche
en vue d'une alternance en 2027 en tout
cas vous l'avez compris elle va vraiment
pas très bien réaction Michel prasan à
ces propos de Daniel Bono on peine à
qualifier ce genre de propos de deux
choses soit elle n'y comprend rien ce
qui est possible mais absolument
insupportable vu son
rôle au sein de son mouvement politique
et le rôle qu'elle tient à l'égard du
peuple français soit c'est d'un cynisme
absolument
insupportable soit
voilà elle partage en fait on ne sait
pas au fond mais dans tous les cas je
trouve que c'est absolument
insupportable et je suis d'accord enfin
je veux dire ça fait des semaines voire
des mois qu'on entend ou qu'on attend de
voir venir l'acte de décès de la la
nuupes il faudrait que enfin il soit
officialisé c'est dit Yanis roder on
vous a demandé une carte blanche ça fait
évidemment maintenant 3 jours que
Dominique Bernard a été assassiné le
cauchemar se répète oui et non myiam oui
parce que c'est à nouveau un enseignant
qui est assassiné et puis non parce que
l'islamiste qui a assassiné Samuel
paatti en 2020 lui reprochait d'avoir
montré une caricature du prophète de
l'Islam il avait un motif précis dans le
cas de Dominique Bernard l'assassin
n'avait aucun motif particulier cela
nous renvoie finalement à la différence
entre les attentats de janvier 2015 qui
visaient des journalistes et des Juifs
et ceux de novembre qui visaient tout le
monde et ça on l'avait pas compris je
n'en suis pas certain Myriam s'il y a
des gens bien sûr qui semblent avoir
intégré le fait qu'on avait eu là une
sorte d'ouverture des des possibles
nombreux sont ceux qui se sont retrouvés
surpris par ce nouvel acte terroriste
comme s'ils ne semblaiit pas avoir
intégré ce que signifiait l'assassinat
de Samuel paatti que voulez-vous dire
précisément dans la foulée de ceux qui
publiquement ont osé avancer que Samuel
Paty avait froissé avait manqué de tact
certains se sont rassurés consciemment
ou inconsciemment en pensant que paaty
avait finalement fait quelque chose qui
lui avait attiré les foudres islamistes
ce qui revient à dire que si on ne
commet pas de maladresse ou d'erreur du
même type on ne risque rien c'est donc
pour vous que ce nouvel attentat montre
que ce n'est pas le cas mais non c'est
en effet ce que montre la mort violente
de Dominique Bernard qui doit nous
obliger à enfin regarder la réalité en
face non ce n'est pas parce que Samuel
paatti avait montré une caricature du
prophète de l'Islam qu'il a été
assassiné mais bien parce qu'il
remplissait pleinement la mission de
l'école de la République qui consiste à
offrir aux élèves la possib de penser
par eux-mêm de construire leur esprit
critique et leur libre arbitre parce que
c'est cela que ne veulent pas les
islamistes ils ne veulent pas de notre
école car pour eux c'est l'agent de la
construction citoyenne l'agent qui coupe
le temps de l'école des déterminismes
afin de proposer l'émancipation
c'est-à-dire la liberté ceux qui
assassinent les profs parce que
maintenant on peut dire cela le font au
nom d'un projet politique et idéologique
qui est l'exact contraire de ce que nous
sommes et de la manière dont nous vivons
libres et égau et ce projet il passe par
la nécessité de détruire l'école de la
République pour empêcher en premier lieu
que les jeunes Français musulmans et
d'abord eux accèdent à cette
émancipation c'est d'ailleurs au passage
le rôle de la baaya prené par les mêmes
islamistes qui vise à enfermer en
permanence dans une entité qui serait
immuable même le temps de l'école mais à
long terme et il pense avec l'éternité
c'est l'instauration partout o ils le
pourront d'un régime dictatorial régi
par la loi de Dieu l'équivalent de ce
qui de ce don vous parliit pour le ramas
alors s'il y a une leçon à tirer de
l'assassinat de notre collègue c'est que
si daesh avait prévenu en 2015 que
l'école serait une cible elle est
devenue dans les faits depuis 2020 et il
est aujourd'hui difficile de ne pas
savoir pourquoi merci beaucoup Yanis
roder une réaction oui dès dès 2015 il y
avait cet article dans daralislam qui
est l'organe de propagande en ligne de
daesh qui appelait très explicitement
euh à cibler l'école et à tuer des profs
et l'article commençait par la
détestation absolue qu'ils ont de notre
vision de la
laïcité de la mixité évidemment ça
l'urait absolument insupportable donc
l'école est une cible et elle est en
permanence réaffirmée dans les discours
islamistes en indépendamment voilà des
des des cours de liberté d'expression et
de laïcité de ce que ce que l'on peut
faire en classe absolument alors on va
prendre un tout petit peu plus de de
légèreté en terminant quoi que avec vous
Fannie on parle évidemment du du pouvoir
d'achat priorité des priorités pour les
Français ces dernières années on a
beaucoup compté les primes Macron mais
ça va bientôt changer et vous nous dites
il était temps oui enfin parce que à
partir du 1er janvier de l'année
prochaine 1er janvier 2024 donc ces
primes la plupart d'entre elles qui sont
aujourd'hui défiscalisé et qui sont
désocialisés c'est-à-dire exonérés de
prélèvement sociaux et aussi d'impôts et
bien elles vont être de nouveau
fiscalisées et socialisées alors certes
c'est vrai que ces primes on va pas
jeter le prob elles ont servi de Coup de
pouce à nombre d'employés qui ont des
difficultés de pouvoir d'achat face à
l'inflation mais mais ces primes les
employeurs les ont beaucoup utilisé et
hier encore à la conférence sociale le
patron des patrons le président du menf
Patrick Martin disait les les montrait
en exemple de soutien des entreprises
vis-à-vis de leurs salariés en disant
que en moyenne un/ers des accords de
salaire dans les entreprises privé
depuis le début de l'année ont versé ont
comporté le versement d'une prime de 900
€ en moyenne alors évidemment ce sont
des moyennes les salariés dans les
grandes entreprises en général sont
mieux loti que dans les petites mais
c'est vrai que quand on regarde la
plupart des grandes entreprises que ce
soit total LVMH et cetera ont versé des
primes et elles ont nonversé alors
qu'elles faisaient des des record de de
Bénéfic et on peut se dire au passage
qu'étant donné les records enregistrés
l'anné dernière elles auraient pu verser
des primes qui soient fiscalisé et
socialiséou ça permettrait aussi de
faire quelques économies c'est la limite
pour vous de de ce dispositif de ces
primes bah oui parce que à long terme
ces primes certes pour le salarié ils ne
cotisent pas pour la retraite pour la
maladie donc c'est un des arguments
d'ailleurs des syndicats qui disent
attention on on rogne le modèle social
et puis le risque aussi c'est que ces
primes elles se substituent à de vraies
augmentations de salaire et alors en
plus c'est un véritable manque à gagner
pour les finances publiques parce que on
a du mal à le chiffrer mais ça se compte
en milliards d'euros h notre modèle
social précisément si on veut le
préserver il faut arriver à le financer
c'est essentiellement pour ça que le
gouvernement remet la fiscalité dessus
c'est ça et oui parce qu'en ce moment
même il y a le budget qui est en train
d't discuter à l'Assemblée nationale
alors le gouvernement a fait le calcul à
partir de janvier 2024 quand il y aura
de nouveau des impôts et des cotisations
sociales ces primes devraient rapporter
1 milliard d'euros aux financesà n'est
pas ce qui n'est pas rien voilà
exactement et puis juste une petite
précision quand même il y a une petite
exception dans les petites entreprises
les moins de 50 salariés normalement on
devrait rester au régime actuel vive
l'impôt sur les primes merci pour ce
parti prix Fanny guinochet Merci à VOUS
Yanis roder elsamondingava à très vite
et Merci à VOUS Michel prasant je
signale que la Chaîne Parlementaire va
diffuser votre film c'est un ancien film
sur Pierre Goldman alors où vous le
savez en salle cartonne le le film de
fiction de Cédric C ce sera le 13
novembre prochain très belle soirée
documentaire sur LCP à
[Musique]
demain